his for the first Monday in sober
October Jesus deep into the
[__] murky waters greeting some
podcast Ville the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by my
bookie listen I go to my bookie for one
reason it's fast it's easy and they pay
when you win let's face it where your
betting is just as important as who you
betting on if you're trying to bet on
the NFL baseball and then May which you
missed out on our Monday Saturday
whatever the [__] my bookies got it I
wouldn't be telling you guys to bet with
them if they weren't the [__] best in
the business
do the smart thing if you're gonna bet
football this season bet with my bookie
whether it's college pro Chinese I don't
give a [__]
now listen right here today right now
you're gonna get this nice and early
it's Monday Night Football tonight you
could double your deposit today right
now use promo code Church CH you are CH
to get 100 percent bonus on your initial
deposit of up to a thousand [__]
dollars okay don't give you don't match
what you deposit visit my bookie dot AG
today right now you read work who gives
a [__] my bo o ki e dot AG and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
you're creating your account to claim
your bonus you play you win you get
[__] paid the church is also
brought to you by zip recruiter listen
cafe our tourist the CEO Dylan Moskowitz
needed to hire a director of coffee for
his organic coffee company but he was
having trouble finding qualified
candidates you know he did he went the
zip recruiter all right zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them with results like that
it's no wonder that four out of five
employees who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
where you gonna get that action at Dylan
posted his job on zip recruiter and said
he was impressed by how quickly he had
great candidates apply listen
more business big business zip recruiter
is as effective for businesses of all
size go to zip recruiter right now try
zip recruiter for free at sip Rikuo
comms last Church again that's zip
recruiter comm slash Church CH you are
CH zip recruiter the smartest way the
hire kicked this [__] mealy it's
a beautiful [__] there to be
alive Monday the 7th of October the
month is [__] mu is the seventh no
yeah yeah absolutely
holy [__] it's the seventh about that
means this week I'm in Kansas City uh-oh
and then Denver on [__]
Saturday night that's how easy we had a
great week last week the kick wall for
sore bug Club a little drunk yeah but
it's got nothing to do with us
understand me uh you know when things
like this happen people whatever what
you guys got understand the basic thing
you guys gonna stand is that we all love
each other very much
so nobody did anything intentional
whatever whatever anything is feeling
everybody's percent right now hopefully
uh in time we'll get over this and
realize we're just [__] crazy
comedian friends you know that's what we
have a couple weeks ago when Andrew
Schultz was on he mentioned a couple
things that didn't bother me they just
really made me want to think and talk to
you guys about it because it's real
[__] important that you get what the
basis of all this that we're doing here
is you know whether it's podcasting
whether it's stand-up comedy whether
you're Jenna cajones and you're drawing
pictures whether you're [__] you know
Bob legacy and you work in an office you
don't we have different things and we
ended up and we chose our lives and here
we are but the weirdest thing that like
if I could go back in time there's one
thing I'd do I'd beat the [__] out of my
guidance counselor let me you guidance
counselor he gave you all the wrong
information there was I don't even know
what they paid those [__] if
there's still guidance
in schools you got to be like certified
by me like you can't go telling people
bad information and the information he
instilled in me which is very easy to
get sucked in by his money
anytime you would choose a career when
you were young people say well it
doesn't make any money you're not what
are you gonna do you gonna be a cop at
35,000 he ain't get shot out by people
pay that for lunch you know with such a
society that's money driven when we're
16 to the age of 18 we can't wait to
have [__] three dollars so we could be
that person with the yacht and the girls
and the [__] bar and the [__] people
hanging around you and the cars and the
limos that's what you really think
that's your basic belief like I can't
wait my life will be so much simpler
when I get to that point we always think
of that point but we never think about
how we're gonna get there especially
from the ages like 18 to 26 you think
you're just gonna bump into it on the
street like it's just gonna somebody's
gonna see it we all have different
fantasies you know like for me it was
like starting like a drug Network and
making six million every six weeks like
I couldn't even [__] control myself
how can you make six million [__]
dollars I couldn't even do little things
how can you may see some million [__]
dollars you know but I still remember
being 24 years old and one day I saw a
picture of a Feroze attested what is it
Ferrari Ferrari Testarossa whatever the
[__] those cars are and I never hung a
hanging on my wall and I had I lived
with a girl and three of the guys at the
time two of the guys it was a four was
four of us and one of the guys came in
my room were talking about some and he
saw the picture on my wall he goes is
that your favorite car I told him no I
gave him some [__] spiel you know
when you're 27 23 whatever the [__] I
was I gave her some just [__] fear I
was gonna be my [__]
car and three years you know and I
remember him looking at me like and like
he was like maybe three years older than
me but he was going he had got his
college degree he was a very smart white
guy very open you know he drank he
smoked dope but he was in a pension his
life like I was watching here I was with
no college education making decent money
at the time working a car dealership and
here he was like you know he had this
tremendous [__] degree but he
couldn't get a job he was heir he would
be up early in the morning and he was
trying to I'll never forget this it's
it's really weird he was trying to he
would go to a thing called Toastmasters
yeah they still have it so he would wake
up like at 7:00 in the morning and go to
Toastmasters to overcome his fear I was
speaking in public and I remember that
I'd be getting up and I'd be eating
breakfast and he'd just be getting back
from the [__] meeting and he had
asked him where the hell have you been
and he was like I was at Toastmasters
and I go what's Toastmasters and he goes
it's like a group of men or women know
whatever the [__] they get together and
we talking and I can say you go to a
place to practice public speaking I
didn't know that people had fear of
public speaking or whatever the [__]
was I was used to public speaking every
[__] day in my life at the deli or at
the bar or on the corner on the
basketball court at one point a day you
know where I was from you had a [__]
take control and talk some [__] if not
they think you're [__] [__] so if
not they thought you were [__] [__]
you were [__] [__] you don't say
nothing so you had a you know to me when
he said Toastmasters I was like what the
[__] are you talking about let me go
down I'll straighten those [__]
right the speech of a lifetime and
comedy was not even on my [__] radar
that but here I went from being this
[__] pathetic loser that just being a
regular loser
and I'm selling cars and I'm snorting
coke and I'm I had a semi-regular life
at the time but I really wasn't going
anywhere and I kept thinking yeah if I
do this and if I do that because I
wasn't like I was just like you guys the
work that was gonna be involved to put
in to become a millionaire or
multi-millionaire whatever the [__] I
was thinking I was gonna be one of those
guys really yeah the work was just too
much like I if they thought I was going
to do if I really thought I was gonna do
it by working like that wasn't gonna
happen like I was making anywhere from 7
to 10 grand a month selling cars in 87
that a lot a lot of money that's a lot
of [__] money and I remember that I
used to be furious about the taxes
Giuliana thought I was a killer about
the taxes and and that was a job where
they gave you a lot of cash bonuses and
that makes it worse when somebody gives
you cash like eight $900 a month in cash
and bonuses oh I would [__] cry like
a [__] kicks you in it's a new tax
bracket you make less money yes so I did
not understand the whole thing of money
but like I'm telling you guys I was very
confused thank you I was just gonna bump
into it and a lot of us do we think well
we're gonna bump into it and then our
lives are gonna be [__] so completely
different I can't tell you how many
times I was laying brick I can't say how
many times I was waiting for a [__]
boss so waiting for a subway in New York
City going all [__] bartending job to
make 1215 hour plus tips I can't tell
you how many [__] times I was like
you know carrying [__] 4 by 12 this
is the dog number four by a playa
sheetrock I'm a million years ago and I
had a camera 4 by 12 sheetrock up four
flights of stairs didn't [__] Hoboken
New Jersey when they were redoing
Hoboken in the early eighties like I did
it all
but would always made me think that this
is coming to an end was that I was only
become rich and then everything was
gonna [__] be hunky-dory like I
thought that when you saw somebody that
had money right away and associated
[__] this big this big bulge of
happiness like in my mind if I had money
I wouldn't do blow anymore I would be
out of him every night I can eat out
every day how I wanted to live my life I
didn't have no idea I had no balance no
nothing I got locked up when I got
locked up it gave me a chance to clean
up in the coke and I saw people that
didn't have money behind bars
trying to act like they had money and
actually finally started hitting me like
that money [__] with people like I
never knew until the age of when I was -
a 25 like when I first saw it how you
know listen a couple weeks ago Felicity
Huffman got I don't know three days in
jail I don't know what she got I say a
month or something like a month in jail
and somebody posted a picture of a black
woman next door that said she got five
years yeah
forgiving a fake address okay you know
the way the law works especially today
you know I was involved with all that
[__] dirty is so I don't know what's
going on today but I could tell you
didn't get any better and it was all
about money you know Jeffrey Epstein
Harvey Weinstein listen you get in
trouble the more money you have the more
you can elude a lot of this [__] that
people with a public defender don't have
there's people sitting in a [__]
general right now in America across our
country that have a sentence that if
they would have had $7,000 the sentence
would have been half because somebody
would have spoken for them somebody
would have fought for him well I'm a
public defender if you know anything
about [__]
attorneys a public offender just doesn't
have one client he has 80 clients and
he's a new attorney and he's trying to
make his bones in the world to branch
out into his own [__] office or
partnership or whatever so he becomes
friendly with the DA's and thought that
about the time in the county or the
state where he practices and it's just
like an agreement like I heard years ago
years ago way before the computer I
heard a cassette playing of somebody
taping a judge's chamber and oh man in
New York City I had nothing to do with
crime that like I was a criminal but I
was not in the system that but I heard a
tape recording once maybe i'm WPIX about
them negotiating a guy's deal you know
so in the public defender goes in to see
Lee he just doesn't have Joey Diaz on
his docket he's got nine guys that he's
gonna see Lee about so he walks in then
it's pretty soon like hey what are we
gonna do about this kidnapping to give
him a mandate of whatever for the six
years put a cap on it and they just run
through them the way you and I run
through a laundry list yeah it's like
any other job it's like any other job
that please you know I'm saying and then
if you go to trial
this guy's got 80 [__] clients how
prepared is he gonna be for that trial
so you know when you watch the OJ trial
you watch any big trial they got four or
five [__] attorneys on on retainer
there but that's not the case or
whatever I learned what money did for
you inside and listen when I got
arrested I had no money you want me to
tell you I had money in the bank and
piles of money laying around the house
I had [__] zero I had zero I had
maybe I had been working I was 25 years
old and I had maybe $32 the bank and
you're making like what 80 grand a year
Wow
80 grand a year with
zero in the [__] listen I always made
money I always made money just waking up
I'm one of those people that leave
let's get an apartment what's the rent
fifteen we split 750 apiece what's the
cable 150 plus the TV I'll just make a
figure up and I know if I keep the
figure under 3000 I don't need a job
3000 I can I can make $3,000 when I was
a kid I could make $3,000 walking around
in a month all right well how much of
that was legal maybe half of it okay on
the tide
you know I was a type of guy Lee he had
a moving job for three days at 200 a day
boom that's 600 yeah this guy's got an
ounce of coke to sell boom that's 400
this guy's that needs to shift something
to carry meat for two nights this guy
needs two nights on loading trucks this
guy needs a pound a week carried from
Jersey to New York you know have the
balls to do it I'll give you 500 cash I
could walk around make $3,000 I did it
all my life
it's okay I didn't I did it just
breathing just breathing you think of
the money I spent on blow just the last
seven years from 2000 to 2007 I was
getting a hundred and twenty-five
dollars and set that what money was I
making and I was still making 15 at the
Comedy Store if I did The Improv or
anything else they'd give me anywhere
from a buck 25 to 175 I was still
putting $2,000 a month in my nose Jesus
my monthly coke bill and cat and drug
bill we'd had a B you figure 60 and
night times four that's 240 there's a
thousand a month war that's a thousand a
month that's just if I did a grandma
night for nice most nights I pop two
grams some weeks I snorted five nights
instead of four nights
well I always averaged 4/9 plus two 280
in our bags of weed I bought
[__] week so I think we're skipping
out a little bit because you said you
when you were younger money was really
important that sounds like at this point
money you didn't even care about no but
that's not the point okay okay I'm sorry
when I was just trying to make a point
in you can make money when I was your
age I can make five just waking up god
okay eating breakfast out no groceries
at the house eat three meals out I
didn't drink right you follow me so I
went without in most areas would people
go with and that's how they blow their
money I didn't buy underwear I just
would you know I got it was straight
[__] I bought socks I'm what gene you
know I care all that stuff I didn't go
on vacations I didn't go to concerts I
didn't do any of that money
my money was for house bills eating and
snort that was my money dating women
whatever the [__] you did alright and
when I came out of prison
I mean we got a job selling cars and I
went back to the making money I sold
Mitsubishi and I went back to making
yeah between 5:00 and 8:00 at this place
okay after taxes and the whole thing it
doesn't bang out to a lot of money you
know plus interning trumpet Didier when
he started making more money when you
snort more oh absolutely yeah okay boy
you [__] make them more in my my
raising was the more you [__] made
the more you spent in you knows your
friends Maureen I will make more
tomorrow there's always tomorrow
there was always [__] tomorrow there
was always tomorrow
and every job and every move that I made
had to be around money okay I was a
slave to money like 90% of Americans are
oh it's huge for me I am now it's
getting less but it was huge for me but
you also have to remember when you're 21
and you're in that middle range you
attribute everything to not having money
wait till I have money and I'll have a
girlfriend wait till I have money then
I'll be happy wait till I have money I
don't have mindless [__] together and
that's what I want to discuss how wrong
that attitude is to have everybody
thought that once boom you think cuz you
could win the [__] lottery fifty two
million that the next day every day is
son the next day is sunshine the world
the universe karma just doesn't give it
to you like that
you got to lose something along the way
you got to sacrifice something along the
way that's why I was so hard you know it
was so hard for me to get on stage
because the thought of not making money
cringed me it's part of the reason why
it took me so long it cringe me the idea
of starting something right now if I
went to one of you guys I know my buddy
Matt Oh Maya up and [__] Milwaukee
you know he works through that I don't
know what the [__] he does I could see
he works hard or whatever if you're
working you know you're learning a trade
whatever when you come to me right now
let's say I okay let's say I do brick
okay let's say I do brick work I do
residential brick work a little bit of
commercial very lightly okay like just
maybe two stories of 12 inch block
that's it
maybe one roll of scaffolding like I'm
one of those guys you know like that's
it and I have my crew is me and two
other Mason's and three laborers okay
and we work a full summer and the one
kid has to leave I got one kid that's a
duds he just wants to shovel make
[__] cement and make sure we're all
happy off
making sure the cement is moist making
sure we have bricks making sure we have
more da more ah my smaller mortar you
know like making sure their job is done
when you're a hottie that's what you do
you you have three bricklayers
and you have to be one step ahead of
them and that's the pain the entry level
the entry level when you're you know
you're putting in sixteen scoops of sand
into a cement mixer or eight I don't
know the bag of whatever then you put in
hose water in there and then you dump it
into the thing and you mix it up really
good then you put it into wheel barrels
and you give it to them and bucket so
they have like a thing a piece of wood
you lay it on let's pretend you come to
me I I'm watching you every day I'm
watching and you're talking to the last
guy on the line the Boozer guy that's a
great you're talking to him and everyone
so uh I see that he has you measuring
putting a level on the wall and he shows
you something or every once in a while
he goes come in and he makes you pick up
the spatula and put it on I'll pour you
decide one day after work and I go
listen here's the deal I could see you
have a mild interest in this [__]
game with doing here what am I paying
1250 now I'll tell you what I'll do I'll
give you a 15
I won't hire another guy you're gonna do
both those jobs but when your job is
done
you're gonna come next to me and lay
brick so you're gonna be a hottie you're
gonna be a hottie and you're gonna learn
how to live breath got it and you're
gonna join the Union and that night
you're going to go to a vocational
school where they do it again like it in
the old days I don't know about today I
don't yell at me in the old days if you
joined a laborers unit and then you
joined the bricklayers Union they had an
apprenticeship program you had to have a
certain high school diploma you had to
have certain grades in high school but
when you start there the union and
you're a union whatever and you're in
between it's the same thing you're
assigned to three masons
once the Masons are taken care of and
all the paperwork's picked up and all
the [__] bricks for tomorrow I'll put
in no situation is over there cuz
tomorrow they're gonna be moving over
there so that's probably 3:30 in the
afternoon so till the Sun comes down
you're gonna go over and lay brick with
this guy and every day you're gonna get
more and more duties and some day none
zero doesn't come in and guess it's
gonna lay brick that day for none zou
and you're gonna also make mortar and
you're also gonna make the coffee run
and you're awesome when we're gonna be a
newspaper you know we're gentlemen here
nobody's thinking another slave we're
paying you it's what you did but I'm
also charging 30 hours an hour for you
okay okay so anybody who knows labor
when I pay you $10 an hour I gotta pay
that other thing $10 an hour I forget
what it is unemployment
whatever so you're not really worth $10
now me you're really worth $20 an hour
to me so that's when you being looked at
by an employer after everything one's
compañera thing has double that right
okay now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
bill you out as a HOD carrier so I'm
gonna bill you out at three days with
three hard carriers and led to my
estimation at fifty five dollars a day
or 65 I don't know what they get
don't [__] quote me on this [__] but
you're still gonna get your $15 for
three years I don't feel bad because
you're getting an education and even
though you're still running around with
other hotties and that telling you how
they're walking with 27a now in the
Union
you're gonna go [__] where's my money
and then one day boom there you are
you're HOD carrier now you're getting
your 26-28 and your [__] overtime and
your benefits and all that stuff that's
a few unit
I'm saying if I'm just a mom and pop
operation it works the same way but
somewhere another you're gonna give up
stuff some days I'm gonna go leave
guess who's working Saturday you alright
and guess who's running the show you are
you're gonna go Wow usually a guy that
runs the show gets till your finals now
not today I'm doing that wiped your ass
three years ago so until that time till
you're really really ready to do this
whole wall by yourself he's gonna throw
ball by yourself no not yet
okay then then shut your [__] trap
right and and that's the same thing with
comedy like I started [__] around
with calmly in like 89 December of 89
and I didn't get on stage to the cent
I told July or June of age of 91 that
procrastination I can lie to you guys it
was fear but the other procrastination
was if I get into this how am I gonna
feed myself you know I had that that
opportunity about the hot carrier right
I had it that's why I know I work well I
and correct me if I'm wrong but I think
comedies a little different in that you
don't have at least with the the hottie
you're making minimum wage ten whatever
you're making at least where I am I'm
almost two years in if I get fifty
dollars it's huge
that's a party if I like that's a you
shouldn't even get a dollar - you're in
it for four years rubber that's not a
dollar so it so it's even less over it
see like I was fortunate my first year
in comedy I was picking up $50.00 every
Tuesday Wow
I'm at 2400 a year my first cheering
comedy for two years I had a certain gig
that paid me $50 a week and you people
like Joey 2400 a year really yeah yeah
and guess what I was [__] proud of
every 424 those are laws I was proud of
every one of those dollar bills every
one of them I would take them home
and a [__] went well that money never
made it on well I would look at those
fifty dollars in an envelope every
Tuesday and go I can't believe they're
paying me because people at my level
don't get a dime for five or four years
right like my second gig they basically
gave me a $5 bill for gas and the gas
door it was a [__] two-hour drive
what five hours what five hours five
hours don't cover got to it yeah but
that's what it was
okay so it was really weird when I got
into comedy before I even entered comedy
I had to do something and for six months
changed how I was thinking I had a
change my thought process completely I
had to change my thought process if I'm
not wrong
I remember writing it out but I'm not
gonna make any money for ten years now
after writing it out the reason why it
didn't scare me that much was because I
had confidence and what I was doing in
the daytime on the streets whether it
was bringing back coffee machines at
that time I was the [__] you know I
was a tile I had laid tile with a guy
basically I quark tile he would [__]
lay the tile and I would get in there
with knee pads on and [__] fill it
all in I forget what it's called and
then [__] wash it down and I would
break my back for [__] I think he
paid me $75 a day cash he was a cheap
[__] I broke my [__] ass for that I
also realized one day when I got to come
and I couldn't be doing my drug activity
and if I did do a drug activity I had to
keep it to a minimum
because if you're an open mica or you're
in a feature act and for some reason you
got arrested and it gets out it's gonna
be a rough [__] season for you for a
couple years
that's a three-year setback because you
can't be trusted
just it's just a blemish you
you're starting out and already you're
ending up in [__] jail we're getting
in trouble right I don't own this in my
club I yeah especially we had I don't
want to live honking car I don't want my
[__] club he's already getting in
trouble he got a trouble for drugs it's
not worth it he's not even a job yeah
he's not even nothing why would I want
on my drunk well you know the first time
you do something on a triple run they
just can't see Tribble wouldn't even
tolerate that [__] you know he would
play with you a little bit he understood
how Paul ISM and comedy and on stuff but
didn't even play with you so I knew
right then when I got into comedy that
my criminal activity and had a curve and
Here I am in the height I'm [__] guys
I'm doing comedy for years and I'm
feeling it I am feeling it for the first
time I like what am I feeling I'm
feeling them maybe just maybe I could
start going on the road and playing
clubs but that's the point of my career
I was that I had already done 20 weeks
of treble work but I was feeling so
[__] good like I'm like you know what
I'm ready for a club now whatever they
throw at me emcee feature I'm ready I'm
ready I was crawling clubs I'm trying to
get emcee work I haven't borrowing money
and a kid gave me [__] rent to the
car for me for me to drive to Arizona 16
hours and showcase in those days you had
to drive and showcase them put yourself
up and I got down there and somebody was
in Jersey and somebody was from the
Bronx and one thing led to another next
you know I was sleeping on the couch
wolf that saved me 40 hours or a nap in
the car and 22 chiropractors you know
they made breakfast that saved me money
you know then the guy said why don't you
stay again tonight and do some guest
spots tonight and I stayed again the guy
who you could stamp my place again you
know again the universe always takes
care you but you have to make the first
step towards that universe you know I
was telling my
duh this is an embarrassing story this
is just a story that I should tell you
guys because this is something that
happened there's a one of my daughter's
teachers when mercy was just in pre-k
whatever the [__] my wife and her became
tight my wife and her and another
teacher became tight my wife is still in
very good standing at that preschool
they go out and some nights the mothers
go out they go to [__] that bar on
the corner and they talk or whatever but
this particular teacher lives by herself
you know she is a hustler I mean she's a
[__] non-stop
she walks dogs she takes care of kids
she'll pick your kid up and drive to
school for the extra small 20 you know
it never ends on that she's a hustler
and she likes my wife's cooking so
there's certain nights that if my wife
cooks something I'll say hey text her
tell her come over and we got the the
Dodger game line she's a big-time
[__] Dodger fan and I gotta tell you
something guys when she comes over I
love it because it keeps my wife out of
my ear it keeps my wife entertained
which my wife needs cuz all day long
she's talking to a child
or she's talking to mommy mommy mommy or
she's talking to me him says I've told
while you need to talk to her the
[__] adults about whatever I don't
get it what they talk about when there's
when she's there this lady's usually in
the kitchen standing with my wife and me
and my daughter watching TV until I get
ready to go to the comedy store there's
some nice lawmen economy still my wife
for calling sir hey miss we'll ever
stand over tonight so don't sweat the
small stuff
she's leaving at 6:00 I don't I call my
office at night I smoke dope it's like
she's not even there she probably spends
tonight so we get past really late so
when she comes over eats sunlight she
comes over eats leaves goes to a Dodger
game and then since she lives like up
the [__] then 101 she just crashes in
the house takes a shower in the morning
bring us clothes and goes right to
school over here
I don't even see it by the time I get up
you got
the room was clean she makes the bed
very self-sufficient the point of the
story was when I was [__] broken [__]
this is a weird story when I was broke
as [__] I was living in Bouldin I was
given all my money
it went 5050 those days after we went to
the attorney and I have a one of my
[__] nose and the other half went to
Chinese food I was swimming at the Y I
was lifting weights in my apartment I
didn't have cable I just had a I don't
know five I think I stole cable from the
landlord
I had the cable I stole the wire to the
TV and I connected to my TV I was a
[__] mess but there was a kid I
worked if I worked or a sports betting
service and my first job wasn't very
good you know it wasn't that I was very
good it was I was snoring so much coke
that it had blocked when you snort so
much coke it's it it blocks the
communication from your brain to your
heart to your words that's why if I did
coke the night before I had a big show I
always ate a bag of dick I always felt
like I was up on stage with no control I
was just saying the words so it's weird
I was a good salesman but I was in such
bad shape psychologically the divorce
you know the kid I wanted to do stand-up
comedy Here I am calling people
tormenting them for their credit cards
you [__] you know it just wasn't the
[__] fun place for me but I would go
home at night and I would go to my
little apartment and I would take a
shower and go do comedy you know and
sometimes even if I didn't have a spot
I'd still go to a spot because I'm
looking for a spot and somebody would go
I guess what
Timmy Jones has a room two miles from
here it's a shitty pizza place but just
by me showing up there I got to do a
spot somewhere else I mean I gave me a
pizza and he gave me a pizza go home so
[__] what turn you know that's what
you do but there were nights man when
they would just catch up to me the whole
week would catch up to me and I was
young and virile and I was you know I
slept 3-4 hours at night and there was a
guy with a his name was Sam
me I used to call him Sam Sammy funky
cold Medina Sammy was maybe my age at
the time we were both in our early
thirties yeah yeah
but Sammy and hooked up with a 50 year
old Chinese woman that was one of the
most nicest people you have a man in
your life a family owned a couple
Chinese restaurants in Boston Wow this
is how big time she was they met in
Connecticut and they dated for a couple
of years and they moved out to Boulder
to try to do whatever the [__] they were
doing I used to call her white powder MA
cuz she was Chinese and he's calling
Sammy funky cold Medina and when I was
at my darkest guys I mean when you're
doing comedy and you're not making
progress I was making progress but I
wasn't I wasn't up to the progress where
I wanted to be you know like I was
making progress and I didn't know it
just me going out every night and riding
and dedicate myself to it and you know
missing out on parties and always doing
comedy first by 94 I had already made a
certain discipline for myself that this
is what it's gonna be there's no
weddings there's no nothing
this is it if you want to do after I saw
like this amo I was done that's this is
how it's done there's no other way if
you want to do comedy but there were
nights man that there was really nothing
going on like on the weekends I could do
a guest spot at McKelvey's or [__]
wit's end or the other Club in those
days the comedy works wouldn't give you
a guest spots and I wasn't a regular so
my Sunday through Thursday I was busy as
[__] Tommy Weis Friday and Saturday I
would have a deck and this [__] dude
would call me up I live maybe 50 yards
from his house I would go up to his
house I would go upstairs his wife would
cook something for me Chinese Szechuan
beef shredded pork twice cooked pork
make it a house and a wok restaurant
style she used to make egg rolls she
used to make spareribs and I would go
over there he
a lunatic and then they would ask me to
stay and watch a movie with them and my
choice every night was that stupid war
with Bruce Willis and Damon Wayans when
they're he's a football player and Bruce
Willis is a detective and Eddie Griffin
was in the movie Eddie Griffin was the
DJ in that movie and I must have watched
that movie a hundred [__] times I
would watch it over and over and over
this is him how nice these people were
the last boy scout the last boy scout
this is our my steez people one of me if
I was watching someone that TV they
would say Joey we're going to bed the
refrigerator is yours if you need to
call anybody the phone is yours Wow
the remote is yours stay here I did that
legs maybe 20 times and then they
started selling me dog
just spend the night when you wake up
she'll make you breakfast you go home
you take a shower we'll drive to work
together and that's what started
happening and it was like I would stop
and try to get groceries for them they
took it but they didn't like it they
knew the situation I wasn't they just
took care of me they just took cami if I
had a show somewhere that was 30 miles
or father they would drive me well I
don't know that if they would drive me
and pick me up and take me back and he
wasn't a comic he just worked no he was
the farthest thing from a [__]
comedian they was but he just took care
of me just out of the kindness of his
heart I'll never ever ever forget that
we stand in touch for a couple of years
we stayed in touch for a while and then
we lost contact and then he got my email
somewhere another and we connected while
I was shooting the longest short not
after it came out while I was shooting
it we connected I told them I sent them
the pictures you know and he was really
happy for me and [__] him and the
Chinese chick broke up she went back to
the boss and the father died
- ten million okay so there was no news
of being with him anymore and he was
doing and we got along till about two
thousand six and then he made a bad call
he called me up asking me to hook him up
with Adam Sandler and Joe Rogan and I
said I couldn't do that because that's
the reason why I'm friends with them
because I've ever break that trust and
he took it the wrong way and never
called me again and that's what happened
but the moral for that story was that
now I get to do this for the school
teacher that's a young girl that's great
she's great to me she knows I get hired
she giggled for my mind you know it's so
weird how life repeats itself it's so
weird how you know I was having a rough
listen there's a couple reasons why I'm
having a rough [__] weak
psychologically you know for starters
this November 8th is gonna be my
mother's 40th death anniversary and
Tuesday which will be the 8th tomorrow
yeah dad was stuck on my that was it
that was a right now 40 years ago that
was her last month and she didn't know
she was gonna die you know and you
didn't know and I didn't know what I'm
trying to think if anything and then
Thursday night I was sitting there with
mercy and I go my wife had like a PTA
thing like so I know Terry if you want
I'll drop you off at the school I'm
gonna take mercy with frozen yogurt area
psych at 7 o'clock at night what's wrong
with you I don't give a function he said
while at dark anyway so we went to this
frozen yogurt place and we're sitting
there guys and she asked me a question
about her being a baby
and her crib and I go why you asking
about this now and she goes because I
kind of remember and I go yeah yeah
you're absolutely right I go was an
awesome I go you know gave me that quick
mercy Ralphie man gave me the [__]
crib your uncle Ralphie is dead he's and
now he's with the Angels he had all
sudden three kids and a man walked out
of the [__] store and all sudden I
saw the three kids stop and say
something to the man and the man turned
around opened the door walked in and
there was Matt oh gee
number one no way together Ralphy and me
used to buy the weed from well Ralphie
and me Ralphie used to put the weed from
man oginam I've already talking about my
best but anyways that's a weird I have a
smoke they came in they gave me a hug
and he shook my hand and we talked a
little bit because you know I still
think about you and Ralphie because I
got until the vapor business into the
cbt business because I still grow Matt's
number one oh well he goes uh I'll give
you a call next week and we could meet
here or something like that I'll give
you a little bag I got left that I just
grew and this he walked out he goes it's
weird Ralph he's gonna be gone two years
and it was yesterday I was just gonna
say it's so quiet couldn't believe it
was two years [__] two years so this
week was just long when he told me you
all like them just that was Ralphie
sending me a message
but that was Ralphie just that that's
the kind of those are the kinds of signs
I get from the spirits they send me a
message from times and you heed he sends
me [__] weed yeah I'm [__] sittin
here I went to the comedy store they
just noticed I was here the other night
oh it wouldn't he had a Heineken
yeah okay I came by the yard line after
the comedy store and I'm sitting in this
[__] chair the doors wide open I came
over here the role of [__] bone and
do something I came over here just to
get out and I came over here and I sat
right there and all of a sudden I said
to myself wouldn't it be funny if the
fruit guy 7:30 and sure enough two
minutes later bang the papaya pinger
papaya and I go [__] Ralph relives
this is just last week so I didn't I
thought his death anniversary was the
17th
that's how confused I am that's how
[__] [__] up I am
but anyway my heart goes after the my
family and I still won't prayer from
yesterday a little candle I'll cut a
chicken heads off one day this was Jesus
I gotta cut a chicken you get some
[__] blood into it but back to the
money thing it was so weird for me to
say okay I'm gonna give this comedy
should a try but I made myself a
decision I said I'm not gonna quit but
before I get involved I'm not gonna make
money for ten years so you were too you
already know that was a 10-year process
I was I had already in 1993 when I went
for it because up to 93 I was driving a
limo I was doing everything I could and
not putting enough effort into comedy
you know miss Amy I just the effort
really wasn't there I was showing up but
I was showing you know it's like I think
the people that go to work every day
from 9:00 to 5:00 and then go to a spin
class at 7:00 I [__] applaud you I
[__] applaud you I do four things in
a day I can't man every night I go I'm
gonna go to kickboxing at 6:00 and it's
twenty to six one way listen literally
I'll make kickboxing I'll make
kickboxing every day at 9:00 a.m. at
night I can't do [__] just do [__]
Kali so when I got into the comedy I
swear to you guys in 1993 November 93
when I moved back October of 93 when I
moved back to Colorado I said I'm
dedicating my life to Carly I've I do
coke
I'm with women I'm [__] nuts and you
know what I'm still not happy so even if
you true a bunch of money at me but you
know I lost my daughter I [__] lost
my mother I went to prison you know I
had a I had a point where I had nothing
[__] going
and I said well this is the best time to
get in the [__] family like we said
the other day nobody shows to an open
mic on the Lamborghini you know and when
I got into comedy I never let that get
in my way I could be honest if you all
the way I told you guys the story about
that lady that I used to do free sets be
pleased tell me why do you do free sets
she should at least give you 20 bucks I
don't want her [__] money and I'm
gonna show her that I'm better than she
is and then the end she's dead and I'm
still here rocking and rolling so what
are you [__] trying to tell me here
the gift of any art the gift of your
life guys the biggest thing you can
overcome right now I know you got a lot
on your plate I know you don't Joey
you're coming from a weird place no I'm
not coming from a weird place I slept in
plenty of corners I slept on plenty of
park benches I slept on [__] couches
I slept on floors don't tell me I didn't
[__] do this [__] yes let's be honest
let's put it on the table it was my
fault partially because of my ghost and
my little things but I did sacrifice a
[__] lot and I'm telling you one
thing I didn't think of money that's why
I had to Taco Bell commercial well
you're that 98 oh so then it didn't take
ten years but that wasn't comedy I guess
so it wasn't calm right no it wasn't
currently sober I know you had the coke
issue and you had your daughter so there
were some things that you didn't have a
perfect life but in those five years
were you happier were you up [__]
let me tell you something Here I am and
just a lot of you guys are young you
don't know before Nissan it was Datsun
[__] in 1996 let me tell you what 95 I
had a Datsun b210 I think there was a
4-speed a 5-speed with a clutch and
four-door
I was don't calmly seven nights a week I
live for today I had zero responsibility
zero responsibility you know my
responsibility was getting work the next
week and I already had 20 fevers out one
of them was gonna come through even if
it was a Friday or Saturday you know I
still remember going up to do something
for Tribble and Michael to the coders
and being all the way up there looking
at the mat there was no [__] thing
looking at the map and saying [__] I
gotta go through like four states to go
home that's what I learned about doing
comedy in the way back and I called this
couple and they was Dean and Dana McGraw
knew her but they had a company called
something entertainment and one of the
few times I you know you know I like
right now the biggest complaint is I
can't make a good tape or good luck
you're never gonna make a good tape if
you know you're getting taped right yeah
so one night I went somewhere when I got
off some guy said hey man I had my
camera roll do you want the footage and
it was like one of those nights I did
like 20 minutes and 14 if it were good
it was a bar and you can hear it and you
could see it and I sent it to them and
they called me back they sent me a
letter saying you'd call headline and
I'm like oh boy these people really
don't know what they're doing I got way
[__] 20 minutes and then co-headline
I mean I didn't have 20 minutes there's
a lie I didn't have 20 minutes 20
minutes was the stretch because I was at
a bar show right yeah this was like six
minutes and I looked at on and I send
them the tape and I'll never forget just
saying let me give him a shot and giving
him a call and I'm going we got a gig
but it's Wednesday and Thursday and
they're like where are you and I told
what Dakota whenever the [__] the cold I
was and in those days Tribble would pick
you 50 people pay you 50 bucks you were
picked up 50 bucks gee he would send you
a balance of a check for 50 in the mail
which you will get three weeks after you
got or a featuring you will feature okay
Wow fifty bucks
so whatever I'd sad did four nights for
him I had two hundred minus two gas and
the Subway sandwiches I was eating the
veggie in cheese's and I'll never forget
saying I'm in whatever and she goes well
we have a condo and such and such if you
could make it to there you could stay
there for free until Wednesday night and
then they'll put you up in a hotel Wow
okay but it was so hard to understand to
go from loving money to loving something
else where the money doesn't matter
there's a part in your life where a lot
of you people are listening to this show
going Joey I don't know what the [__]
you talking about yes you do
one day you're gonna come to the point
in your life were you gonna go I don't
know what all this fuss was about
I feel the same whether I get a bonus or
where I don't get a bonus I feel the
same whether you know I'm broke or you
know when I grew up I grew up on an
Commission in my room carpeting
cable TV in my room every type of [__]
soda you know I went to basketball camps
my mother [__] threw me money plus I
hustled and I went from having all that
living sharing a bedroom with a guy on a
piece of floor we just threw beds on it
we were six inches apart or the TV was
stolen and we put album covers up around
the room so you would think we had art
in the [__] room so I know what it is
to be living like a doctor to be living
like a [__] Mook and a half hearing
mice in the room things go why are you
sleeping you know I've been there I've
been throughout the [__] whole thing
but trust me in 1996 and 97 and 98 yeah
I had a pain in my heart deep about my
daughter and yes I was missing meals and
yes I was barely making it but ours is
happy
as could be because I was doing what I
wanted to do well that was my question
do you think and obviously people if
they have kids they have to make a
certain amount of money but do you think
if you're really worried about the money
you might not love what you're doing
because like for me like no no no no I
had two spots at the store last night I
could not wait all day to go down that's
my point
and therefore $15 yeah there's no money
there at all that 15 after taxes you
remember I tip out more than I make when
I go down there no that's what I'm
saying so I think about that when I go
to the economy store I tip out more than
what I get I final time and valet
I tip out more than what I get just with
the valet usually yeah just the valet a
tip out and the guy will award their
young comics there are hustling they're
all trying to make a living how can I
not support them so that's where you
give back when you get older as and hold
the comic that's how you give back by
helping out the younger [__] comics
you know it's nights I go to [__]
park my car as I walk out Shing foul the
Chinese kid and some other white guy
walking out with a [__] thing full of
garbage that was not included in there I
want to be a comedy resume dream but
there at the store there are amongst
great comic there in the [__] energy
that they're involved people are talking
to them you know when I see them dump it
you know I I feel in my arm but I ain't
that was [__] me 20 or 30 years ago
at wit's end I had to take garbage out
and the worst is when you go throw a
thing out the bottle hits the floor and
that old beer hits your jeans and I got
a drive home sticking like an old beer
with a barber or in it or the bag
emerges like that
I am yeah when I go down the comedy
store I lose money when I woke up
economy store and I lose it on purpose
because you have to give back you have
to give backs at some point all these
things Sammy the [__] chicken
Nebraska all these things that people
give you
you have to give back the knowledge that
they're getting from you is it the $20
then now is there getting from you is
how you should hold yourself up as an
old to comic as an older man you know
I'm trying to make up all the [__]
mistakes I made as a young kid I saw him
trying to be the best I can on a daily
but I didn't you know when I got to talk
about commercially that money yes put
coke in my nose but that money went to a
big chunk of child support that money
went to a big chunk of an attorney that
I owed money to and a big chunk of that
went to the strip where I live with for
rent and God knows what else because she
was charging me back rent or you know me
I guess in July in Seattle I'm taking
that here she was as cheap as [__] Jesus
so that's why I had a robber half the
time I give it three and then take one
out of the purse just to make it even
somewhere it's gotta be an even playing
ground it's not all about you
but that'd do not only then I was worth
living on the road at [__] a hundred
said tonight after the Taco Bell
commercial went down I disappeared in
one on the road the the CBS pilot
commercial that money I got half of that
went to the attorneys half of that went
to the stripper that's how we got our
apartment on Hollywood Boulevard and the
other half went just to have money in my
pocket and I didn't know what it felt
like to have more than four miles in my
pocket at one time since 1991 to 1998 I
didn't know it was like that four
hundred dollar bills that belong to you
because I would basically go cat even
when I worked at the sports betting
place I would catch a check and have to
make eight money order so people I owed
money to a 10-9 money honest if I made
$3,000 I knew twenty-five of that was
going out I pay my debts I got a pan
what do I'm gonna do I got a [__] pan
you know don't get me wrong I told the
credit card companies and people to suck
my dick
damn their Maybelline oh yeah yeah the
people who mattered the people man had
to pay back I borrowed money from a dear
friend of mine
how to make a [__] payment one with
him after I made bail you know there was
a thousand people I had to make right
with and you eventually pay the credit
card back no I did it oh no I thought
that was that what no no those are the
pay my watch credit card long back okay
I'm talking about my debt from 90 to 993
it takes seven years for it to disappear
off Europe
oh it just goes away yes I don't know
but it's six years of them Hey hi Lee
how are you jo from Discover card you
know st. right you got to pick up a
phone to call your mom a payphone and
before you could pick it up it would
ring and it'd be Joe from discover how I
see they you remember cuz they used to
you know there was no website in those
days but when somebody posted I was
gonna be somewhere like a fly I don't
know from from 92 to 97 in Seattle until
I got the 1-800 line I got calls
everywhere they would call the comedy
underground CL collectors
three years later because what the big
companies do is sell to a smaller
company for a percentage of it for 25
cents on a dollar they try to recoup
their money so it's constantly and it's
just a write-off so somebody told I was
ready to go file for bankruptcy and
somebody said no file bankruptcy just go
underneath go underneath and don't
answer the calls and eventually little
things dropped off will things dropped
awful thing I was very devastating for
me I don't like owing money now I had
put myself and such a credit card debt I
had put myself in such a credit card
debt and it wasn't for me it was despite
my ex-wife years later I realized that
it was despite my ex-wife so she would
get burdened with the debt a man enough
to admit it you know and then they threw
it out of court and I got stuck with the
[__] debt play so at the end of
backfiring after my [__] thing you
know so you pay for you reap what you
sow you know but that was a big thing
that people really don't understand if
you don't love what you're doing I say
this to people all the time if you can't
do it for free
the only people say hey what are you
doing on Sunday Lee and you like nothing
on me how you want to help me move
there's pizza in Rome and you're like I
think I got a podcast you know thank
goodness yeah
if we don't love something we don't tend
to do ya want to help out our friend
we'll go over and pick him up you know
like that day with the tape we call John
salami we have some friends that helped
us you know but I'm talking about once
you do something just for the money it
wears on you
so before quickly before you go ahead
was there any point in this ten years
whatever however many years it took you
to start making money that you were like
you know what I hate these calls let me
go make some money and forget comedy I
was so deep in the hole again you asked
me a couple of weeks ago we go through
it every three or four months when do
you know when do you know when do you
know when I put my debt down on that
news on that piece of paper and I added
it up I forget what the number was I
really don't genuinely do but it wasn't
a good number like a hundred grand
it doesn't double that Wow okay so
here's the deal people if I owe you 200
thousand you come to me and you a Joey I
need that 200 G's I could give you 25
grand the year or every six months
whatever the term is we come to but once
you're running the clock on me you're
never gonna get that oh yes with the
credit cards exactly one to do think 20%
interest it's 20% and the clock is
always running so if your minimum
payment is $20 and you're making a $50
payment you're in no danger you're in no
danger for a long time I was
making these minimum payments and I
would look to see it what I owed and I
realized that no matter how I came to
terms with it you know I went to a
consolidation company oh I don't know
who it was back then in nineteen before
I left for New York in 93 January 93 or
92 one of those years I went to see one
of those debt consolidation whatever he
said to me it was not gonna work like it
was like he couldn't narrow it all down
to 1,200 a month for 14 years and that
was about me living me paying child
support me paying the attorneys that was
just a credit card bills
Wow he would have broke it down into two
loans for me even though I didn't that
was since I didn't have credit it would
have put me into a high risk so my
interest rate would have been higher and
Lee it was just a trap that I would have
had a bankrupt anyway there was no way
there was no way I could pay the credit
cards child support the attorneys and
live a life there was no way I was not
living a grandiose whole life and I was
trying to if I could sell an Eightball
to cut back on me spending a 50 I would
do that
I always sold drugs or something just to
cut back on that but at that point I
looked at that number I knew that was a
tape that was unattainable I knew I had
to throw my hands up and as bad and as
[__] shitty as I felt for putting
somebody in those conditions you know
you lie to yourself and you tell
yourself things to make you feel better
are they making up an interest they
robbed other people the fact this
remains the same I did all of the money
and that was it I broke I had every card
imaginal you know but there were people
on that dent list that I could told them
to go [__] themselves but I didn't
because I knew them
I knew the time of day giving me the
money that they were going through a
hard time and they believed in me so
those people I called up like a man I
said listen I know I owe you two grand
but all I could say is 50 a month you
know what Lee you gonna get pissed at me
for about a month or two and then you're
gonna go you know what I gotta give the
kid some character links he's doing
Alisha's trying it at least she's and
every month he gives me 50 bucks on the
first and he comes to my house he wins
my daughter a toy and he talks to my
wife and you really can't be mad at
those people that's what I did I did
that one a ton of people I have a friend
of Mississippi I owe thousands to
there's one I still I owe money to and
I've asked 20 people because he gave me
money again another guy that went into a
bank account that didn't have money and
he gave me money to help my dream that
Datsun b210 I talked about right he
bought it
well he bought it 800 hours put the
insurance on it put new tires on and got
it rode ready for me those are the
people I've had touched me in my life
though smile this is why I'm saying to
you that whatever journey you take it's
gonna be hard it's gonna be really
[__] hard when I write write hard on
my pad I ride it with three [__]
exclamation points for it's gonna be
very hard but you're gonna every once in
a while you catch a break whether you're
a carpenter you know you're a carpenter
and you start your own business and for
the first six jobs you break even and
your wife is breaking your balls and
then one day you figure something out on
time or energy or money and now you're
in the profit now you know see it take
it
there's a [__] curve it's a big curve
to figuring out what you want to do
there's a big that's a big curve that's
a big curve for anybody I knock on I
knocked on wood every day and get on my
knees and I'm thankful and grateful that
at the age of thirty you know at the age
of 28 I had the knowledge to get on
stage
or the Jews call it hoods but yeah I had
the hood spot again on stage but then at
the age of 31 I committed to it do you
think about it at 31 to tell yourself
you're gonna be broke for 10 years
that's why I am right you tell yourself
that you look yourself in the mirror and
go you know what I'm gonna stop playing
the organ with a monkey but I'm not
gonna make money for five years anything
but if I do make money you ever go to a
service department and drop your car off
and they tell you your car's not gonna
be ready till five mm-hmm I think you
got a koala Levin o'clock I think your
cars ready like god damn it I want to
rent in a car I'm on the other side of
the town they tell you the worst
prognosis so if they do beat it they
look like heroes
right you know I'm saying if you come to
me today and go I got a lump on my head
what do I got left
I can't tell I don't know I'm gonna
fortune-teller my god
let's put six months on yet for six
months you beaten [__] stabbing people
something discover the suck your dick
well sudden here you are a year later
you still alive yeah but I think also so
like yeah like maybe ten years you're
not gonna make money you're five you're
making a little bit of money now instead
of working for free you're making $50 I
said by year six I was making six to
eight thousand a year by my calculations
that's it one year I did taxes in 97 I
actually did taxes like I filled out the
paperwork and I got all the w2's right
and I think I made $8,000 for the year
now but you're also talking about $4,000
and fifties and twenty-five and
thirty-five dollars from doing bar shows
so almost 2,000 get me wrong yeah I was
making a thousand a month paying 400
rent I had no car payment I had child
support with 365 clothes and food if I
got a score and I already had you know
like I said I always knew I would make a
thousand to twelve hundred a month god
forbid somebody called me out
bloom once I got a gig for you Friday
and Saturday opening for me for 100 a
night oh he's out with the Mexican
dinner right I jumped up and down and
it's interesting you're talking about it
because I had an issue not an issue I
went down to San Diego four weeks in a
row well and I had people offer me
places to stay like you're saying people
are very generous it makes me
uncomfortable to stay at people's places
I've never liked that and I know you
talked about cuz your mom passed away
you did see the highs and the lows did
it take you a while to get used to
sleeping on floors to sleeping on
people's couches before you make the
next step into your journey you got to
reprogram your mind I know it's hard and
get ready to eat [__] and to do what you
need to do have not quit this because
it's not gonna be on an easy journey for
you right it's not an easy journey for
anybody somebody offers you a space to
you're trying to get into a community
yeah you're trying to get into a
community you're trying to find
especially a comic at your level whether
you're a plumber that's you know when
you're an apprentice union plumber right
let's say you're working on a big
[__] job and there's 15 [__]
apprentices where do you go after work
bar a bar and you become bonds with
other guys and you talk to other guys
and these guys aren't the plumbers these
guys are the same guys that are doing
your job they know it is to get rained
on they know it is the pipes to hear
them they know what it is to unload a
truck they know how it is to do all this
[__] those are the people you gotta be
around not the plumbers the plumbers
ain't gonna help you alright the
plumbers hanger [__] is gonna call you
a dummy like what are you doing the [__]
out here go go help him it's the same
thing with comedy it's the same thing in
any journey they're opening your house
to youth you become a part of something
so in the morning you wake up at 12:00
and you go eat Mexican food then you go
see the Joker and they introduce you to
other comics that both have other rooms
you know central or one on the border of
Mexico
one on the border of [__] Numa you
know this is what this is called is
called opening up doors you're opening
up doors you cannot feel weird when
somebody offers you a place to live
because I tell you what the next five
years you're not gonna make any money
right I drove back and forth you're not
gonna make any money you lost dirty on
the weekend for gas yeah you're not
gonna make any money so when you start
working helium they don't put you in a
hotel room right so Pat house a local
comic you're gonna stay at his [__]
on his floor and watch TV and guess what
when Pat House comes out here to stay
for a couple of days he has to stay on
your couch and those are the
relationships I don't care what you
liked like I told you the other night
the other night I had my red sweatshirt
on I did not want to go to the store but
it doesn't matter what I like or what I
need or what I want doesn't matter it's
what needs to be done what I want what I
want is this idiot have somebody sucked
my dick or somebody cuts my fungi
toenail while somebody [__] who feeds
me reefer and somebody brings me shrimp
egg foo yung that's what I want that's
the ideal right yeah but that's not
gonna happen that's not gonna happen so
I got to do what needs to be done what
you like when you become a comic or when
you commit to any career what you like
or what you used to it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work you have to change
for it that's part of the process that's
part of the love that you have for this
but for you to go to San Diego and drive
back and forth for $0 I gotta ask you to
go outside and bang you on the wall come
back in I understand doing it one night
oh you could have spent the date on that
got on the beach take your shirt off go
to a coffee shop write jokes that's all
your job is right now mr. right Joe
that's the only job you got come here
twice a day twice a week and write jokes
okay it doesn't matter where you read it
take that computer and have that pen and
pencil with you get a chicken with a
feather case you got to draw blood from
it there right and that's
all you need to do there's no worry and
then and that's what I understood see at
that age I was raised to Jersey and I
was raised by different dynamics
I was raised when people pull you aside
and said this is how it's done
and this is how it's gonna be done from
now on this is gonna be nothing know why
cuz I'm a [__] idiot and this guy
knows more than me cuz I got to assume
I'm a [__] [__]
because if I was and I'd be doing what
he's doing and I'm not so obviously
that's how I was raised people come up
with you the following games is over
this is what needs to be done the first
time you don't do it you getting smacked
in the mouth you'll do it you'll do it
quickly you were just if he tells you to
be that nine you'll be there at ten
tonight with a [__] flag marching
that's how life is
it's not what you want to do it's what
needs to be done I didn't want to
[__] get into Tommy and Starr for ten
years but it's what it needed to be done
you know people still when we when we
say it now it's well known you get 15
dollars for your spots at the Comedy
Store half the people at home listening
for this right now going why do you go
down there half of the people who have a
mind right now they listening to this
podcast happiest then have a [__]
head on your shoulders that had good
loving growing up and petted your dog
your parents took down vacations you're
like Joey you're 56 years old and you're
doing spots for $15 shame on you it's
not about the $15 I wish it was like I
always told my agents when they call me
and they try to greed me and [__] me
out I tell him Ryan out if I wanted to
make money I would have got into the
coke business and succeeded but I didn't
that was a failure sorry got into this
so this is my [__] future when you
love something nothing could stop me in
you imagine your wife your girlfriend
you haven't seen it for a month
she calls you up one night at 2:00 in
the morning and tells your pussy's on
fire and it's an hour drive I mean
would make the drive come on let's all
not raise our hands at once because
we've all done it ladies we've all been
there how come it's easy to get in the
car and drive 40 minutes to get a piece
of ass but not the thing that you love
the most
we all love [__] and we all love [__]
right ladies good night some guy calls
you one o'clock come over he's
good-looking you [__] fly over there
you don't fly that [__] fast when
it's your job right you don't fly that
[__] fast when you know think about
these things these are things they gotta
think about money is not the answer to
your happiness money is not the answer
to your life trust me on something the
money will come fall in love with
something first do you hear what I was
honey said really really fall in love
with some for something first
we had a guy in here that when you look
at this celebrity Net Worth
he was down 100 million dollars he went
to prison and he's here to educate you
and tell you that greed is not good
passion is good you know when supply
isn't it when I go on Twitter I see
Jennifer Jones an affair on a [__]
Sunday you think Jonathan Jennifer Jones
wants to be on a [__] fair on a
[__] Sunday no but she loves people
buying her art and she loves people
coming up to her and saying that's a
nice piece even if they don't buy the
human interaction you have to love all
this you have to love it and then after
you fall completely in love with it then
you'll figure out the plan how the money
will come in that's the plan that's the
plan
money is [__] no good to think about
passion I want you to love something I
want you to go Joey Jesus I can't wait
to go to the beach to make a [__] ice
castle but there's no money and I meant
right your mother your grandmother your
father there's no money and ice castles
what if one day you become the best ice
cast in the world and every time jay-z
throws a party you shaved the ice cream
for twenty two million dollars what if I
don't know that I don't know the future
with something first and then the ghee
this will come later when I don't know I
don't know but if you deeply love it if
you deeply love something [__]
helping people you know I got a friend
right now I talked to a lot she just got
a job in a rehab
I think she's [__] [__] okay
you know me I'm like gonna sit there and
listen to lies from people for no money
she was a junkie and now her passion she
stayed clean for 15 years
and now her passion is to lead others
she's making 400 a week and she has to
work 60 hours a week she just got
herself an apartment in Van Nuys she
drives all the way downtown every day
she gets there an hour early to [__] you
know what I talked to those people
they [__] inspire the [__] out of me
it makes me remember why I love this you
know Vinny Anna subconscious you said I
would Vinny you talked to Vinny about
jujitsu and you ask him what he really
wants to do and he'll look in the face
and know I love everything about and you
could tell him well he's teaching you
Jitsu he loves everything about it you
know how much money there isn't making
teaching you Jitsu
as much as [__] sucking [__]
backwards okay there's that much money
in teach in jujitsu but let me tell you
something if you really love it you'll
become a [__] millionaire I eat John
Jacques Machado ie Egon Machado I could
bring you ie [__] a Berto crane these
guys love what the [__] they do go look
at their schools any problem Eddie Bravo
ie Eddie Bravo ie Eddie Bravo good [__]
with Eddie and take away the [__]
cosmonauts and the dead president says
he would shake the beat he throws on you
about leg locks and the [__]
knows what he's talking about and he
doesn't miss a call
you know that [__] every night
calls me at 10:00 at to 8:00 and he's
headed downtown to [__] teach Monday
to [__] Thursday what I knew ready
and he was living in a shack on [__]
Santa Monica next to another [__]
animal
they had a Shack down there Shack there
was rabies on the wall you think Eddie
gave a [__] he had he started with a
little gym called the whatever the [__]
it was I'm bomb squad over on Santa
Monica I would go over there across the
street from the Whole Foods whatever it
is now now it's something completely
different
that scent that that supermarket after I
saw from the Godfather who said let them
lose their souls they're all animals
anyway the guy that said that line that
Godfather I seen about that supermarket
and he started a bomb squad do you think
he was making a million dollars at bomb
squad a year no Eddie busted his balls
ever since he he took something he took
a win over a champion and turned it into
something that now it's international
didn't even like a hundred schools and
clock hundred schools something he was
in love with that for years he starved
you lived on the back of a [__] shed
look at him now
so you think I'm [__] lying to you
the proof is in the pudding don't forget
this stirs this Friday night I will be
at the Uptown Theater in Kansas City
Missouri ready to [__] Rock and
Saturday we out of the show
at the Paramount Theater 9:30 you're out
by [__] 11 o'clock you can still
smoke dope till 6:00 in the morning or
whatever the [__] that is you like to do
it what not you understand me you know
how we do it I'm looking forward to
Kansas City last time I went down there
do comedy I was at the funny bone I
think it's a funny bone no no no I think
it said it's an improv and I had a great
time I think I'm gonna go see whatever
is kickboxing school on Friday I think
I'm getting in early enough hopefully
then I can go to kickboxing class so I'm
like so I'm looking forward to some
barbecue I already know or I'm going I
already got the hotel I'm ready to
[__] go but before you go anywhere
this podcast is brought to you by my
bookie Dodd AG the Churchill what's
happened now is brought to you by
my bookie dot AG let me ask you
something yeah asking me Joey why do I
go to my bookie it's fast it's easy and
they pay when you win they revamp their
[__] website it looks [__]
phenomenal you could do prop bets side
bets whatever bet listen they got they
got a contest they were running five
teams you beat the spread
you rack up points on get to sign up a
hundred thousand at the end of the
season I'm sure they're gonna do
something with with college football and
the NBA
my bookie is the way to go but if you're
trying to bet NFL baseball MMA whatever
my bookies got it do the smart thing if
you're gonna bet football bet with that
if you're the kind of guy likes to bet a
little one a lot try a parlay if all
your picks come through you multiply
your winnings and no matter how you bet
the NFL season is the best time of the
year why with two weeks away from pro
basketball with two weeks away from
[__] hockey I think I can get started
already what am I saying
you know college basketball's down the
corner the holidays are coming
we all need [__] Jesus do me a favor
go to my bookie down AG right now double
your deposit today right now this Monday
use promo code Church get a hundred
percent bonus on your initial deposit
are you [__] kidding me or what that
means you lay down the nickel they put a
nickel on top of that where you gonna
get that type action from nobody uncle
Joey's bringing it to you so go to my
bookie that AG that's my bookie grab a
[__] pen my beet oo ki e dot AG and
don't forget to use promo code Church CH
you are CH when creating your account
they claim the bonus listen with my
bookie that AG you play you win you get
[__] paid and don't forget to
check my flavors world my Instagram on
Thursday I'll be dropping a video with
your [__] uncle Joey's my
bookie pics last time I had to lose I'm
not a lot of you people just go to my
bookie that AG right now get the party
started
someone talk to you about Dylan
Moskowitz is a real zip recruiter
customer
we use if recruiting the higher for his
company cafe
I'll Torah the following is a
testimonial script based on the employer
story you know cafe outdoor a CEO Dylan
Moskowitz needed to hire director of
coffee for his organic coffee company
believe he's having trouble finding a
qualified candidate what did he do he
went to zip recruiter zipper cooler
doesn't depend on candidates finding new
it finds them for you technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so you get the qualified
candidates fast
Dylan posted his job on the zip
recruiter and he said he was impressed
how quickly he had great candidates
applied he also used the zip recruiter
candidate rating feature to filter his
applicants so he could focus on the most
relevant ones and how's Dylan found his
new director of coffee yes he did in
just a few days with results like that
it's no wonder four out of five
employees who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
and you could take that to the bank
do me a favor don't see why zip recruit
is affected for businesses of all sizes
whether you got ten employees or 200
employees
you could try zip recruiter for free
Joey what the hell it's Monday free go
to zero google.com slash shirts eh you
are CH that's zip recruiter calm slash
shirt CH you are CH and get the smartest
way to hire that's what zip recruiter
has to offer
it's the smartest way to hire they're
gonna save you time and energy and
you're gonna get the best candidate
available to you I want to thank sip
recruiter I want to thank my bookie but
most importantly I want to thank you
[__] sandwiches for always
having my back man why I talked about
today fall in love with something first
in time you'll figure out how to make
money with it I don't care if it's
shining shoes I don't care if it's
[__] putting yellow paint on people's
[__] if you have passion eventually
your dream will come true I love you
[__] with all my heart
see you Friday in Kansas City at the
Uptown or Saturday night at the 9:30
show at the Paramount Theatre and then a
little Tony better few [__]
this meal Lee